cette semaine l'enquète du poste va
s'intéresser à un poids lourd de
l'animation de tf1 cela fait presque 20
ans que jean luc reichmann est arrivée
sur tf1 qu'il s'invite dans le salon de
millions de français chaque midi avec
ses jeux télé tu as commencé avec
attention à la marche en 2001 le jeu
devenu culte a duré pendant 10 saisons
et s'est arrêté en 2010 pas moins de
3200 30 cette émission était diffusé oui
en effet c'est beaucoup mais jean luc
reichmann a fait encore plus fort avec
les 12 coups de midi le remplaçant
d'attention à la marche avec déjà plus
de 3500 numéro produits aux é-u côté
audience ça marche fort aussi pour les
12 coups de midi avec 3.5 millions de
téléspectateurs en moyenne sur les dix
saisons déjà diffusées
cela fait donc 20 ans que jean luc
reichmann a pris en otage la case du
midi chez tf1 et à priori ça n'est pas
près de changer étant donné les
audiences réalisées par ses émissions en
parallèle mais toujours sur tf1
l'animateur poursuit une carrière
d'acteur dans les eaux mattei brigade
des mineurs
la fiction dont il est l'acteur
principal
on est déjà à sa septième saison et elle
cartonne elle aussi avec près de 5
millions de téléspectateurs en moyenne
avec tous ces succès jean luc reichmann
serait l'animateur le mieux payé de
france avec près de 125 1000 euros par
mois sans compter son cachet pour léo
mattei qui doit lui aussi être important
[Applaudissements]
bref à tous les niveaux jean luc
reichmann est un poids lourd de la télé
mais alors pensez vous qu'il soit là
tous indispensable de tf1 alors c'est
vrai que vous êtes le genre est mal je
pense que c'est un cas unique c'est le
seul qui en dix ans n'a pas perdu un
téléspectateur toutes les émissions ont
perdu koh lanta a perdu de voice chat a
perdu lui il était à 3 millions de à la
première saison il est à trois millions
cinq à la dernière saison c'est vraiment
un cas unique un nom oui la preuve
effectivement que c'est un atout
indispensable mais il faudrait revenir
sur le salaire de jean luc reichmann
125000 eurobonds c'est à la louche c'est
une estimable restent bloqués quand même
voilà mais c'est alors je sais que pour
le spect les spectateurs ça peut
paraître choquant de gagner autant
d'argent mais faut rappeler quand même
faut le placer dans une économie c'est à
dire que l'émission en elle même moi
j'ai des tous deux des spots pub pendant
pendant l'émission
c'est 30me entre 30 et 40 mille euros le
spot de 30 secondes
ça veut dire que si vous faites un
calcul rapide ils se font à peu près 300
à 400 mille euros de rapports de
bénéfices sur les missions et vos
multiples mais vous multipliez vous
marquent 3 puisqu'il y en a une avant
une pendant une après ça fait quand même
beaucoup d'argent ça fait plus d'un
million premier ça reste une fête
commerciale
oui mais sans cela et 125 1000 euros par
mois ça veut dire comme ya là tous les
jours ça lui fait 4000 euros par
émission
je trouve pas ça scandaleux voilà qui
donne alors les 4000 euros pas aimer
change je suis pas grand clerc mais à
mon avis oui c'était il ya pas le
content mais c'est pas mal honnête c'est
ouais le débat il ya un truc
franchement j'ai l'impression que lui il
a créé un vrai rendez vous c'est à dire
que les gens ils disent pas ils vont
regarder telle ou telle émission ils
disent les maîtres richman voilà quand
tu fais ça sur tf1 c'est que tu as
réussi son pari en revanche en tant
qu'acteur par pitié jean luc rabouin
attendait a pas en même temps je pense
oui moi je trouve que son personnage de
léo mateille n'apporte pas grand-chose
qui joue de manière bizarre
voilà alors les gens les miens donc
certainement il est bon mais moi j'aime
pas les jeunes ou des adultes rice il
doit ce que vous aimez jean luc
reichmann
ouais je me fais un capital sympathie
qui pour moi c'est important ce
quelqu'un de que je trouve authentique
et qui en plus de sa s'investit dans des
combats qui sont nobles dames à la cause
des enfants maltraités entre autres et
donc base c'est à mon avis une des
raisons de son succès aussi
sur la chaîne c'est que les gens se
sentent proches de lui quoi bah c'est ça
qu'elle était première tout cas c'est ce
qu'on dit de lui oui mais là où
justement très fort jean luc reichmann
c'est que justement il arrive à berne et
3.5 retraite polichinelle mais jean luc
reichmann au russey hors antenne ce
n'est pas le personnage aussi
sympathique et bienveillance on veut
bien transparaître c'est quelqu'un
excusez moi juste avec ses équipes
parce que je connais des gens qui
travaillent avec lui non mais avec ses
équipes il a la réputation d'être
quelqu'un de 1 c'est pas le débat et non
et j'ai envie de vous dire ce qu'il est
dans la vie à la ville c'est ça le
regarde ce qui compte c'est ce que les
gens voient de lui à l'antenne
impression chien arrêts de jeu tournée
dans l'avion on va parler de benjamin ça
va pas être brûlés soit c'est vrai
j'aimerais voir moi je vois je suis un
gros connard par exemple voilà impliqué
mais vous êtes le plus les années on va
continuer parler de leo matiz parce qu
on a tout un forum sur les métiers et la
promo qui est fait à l'intérieur de
l'émission dans l'udc a tous été bougés
pas position sur jean luc reichmann le
frigo est plein voulais qu'ils voulaient
une leçon de français moi je vous
apprends par les ouïes écouter est-ce
que vous avez un truc intéressant dire
sur luc reichmann alors les et jean luc
reichmann et un animateur à prendre
peut-être pourquoi parce que son contrat
apparemment que tf1 s'arrête dans un an
donc dans un non c'est pas ce qu'il va
se passer avec jean louis bal lâcher et
pour revenir sur ce que disait mon
christophe carrière c'est que au niveau
de son salaire apparemment et
toucheraient des pourcentages aussi sur
les sms tout genre on s'engage lui sur
l'essai mais parlait de son salaire
animateur oui mais voilà non mais
revenons-en ont parlé d léo materi gars
des mineurs c'est une série dans
laquelle il joue je trouve très bien et
est une c'est une création de lui c'est
pour le justement parler des problèmes
des enfants que ce soit couvre gaulle et
il est à la fois créateur cette série
scénariste et il joue très très bien
deux enfants notamment sur mesure est ce
que dit non et alors c'est écrit sur
mesure mais c'est très bien géré c'est
une série importante parce qu'il soulève
les problèmes peuvent rencontrer les
enfants dans les prochains épisodes moi
j'ai vu tous les épisodes il a que
quatre d'ailleurs dans cette série-là y
en a eu deux parties diffusé hier soir
il y en a deux jeudi prochain
c'est sur l'autisme les deux prochains
mais c'est c'est une série importante
qui évoque tous les sujets là urnes à
des enfants et il y tient
particulièrement à mon avis c'est un ami
puisque vous parlez dans le fauteuil du
bâton de dons de mattei
ce qui est bien c'est que lui jean luc
reichmann comme il à l'émission tous les
jours il fait une auto promo quasiment
permanente et on a remarqué c'est assez
nous ont regardés une parenthèse je
profite toujours parce que quand je peux
faire un peu de pub pour tf1 et pour les
eaux mater les prochains épisodes là que
vous allez voir demain se passe dans un
centre d'éducation fermé cette fois où
j'ai fait de la figuration c'est pour un
film qui n'est jamais sorti
je vous prendre dans les eaux mathy du
coup je fais de l'éducation gagne une
avec elle
donc la plupart de mes samedis
après-midi suis très heureux parce qu'en
fait je dis là qui arrive il y aller au
mattei et scellier qui thérapie un petit
peu comment sait on connaît
l'équithérapie oui voilà on vous en
parlait dans les eaux mattei et puis qui
se pratique avec les chevaux jeudi soir
ben oui on va en parler d'équithérapie
il parlait